Thank you to Skillshare for supporting this
episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
And if you are one of the first thousand people
to click the link in the description you can
get a two-month free trial of Skillshare’s
Premium Membership.
There are no ghosts in the microcosmos.
There is no Halloween in the microcosmos.
But if there were, this flatworm would fit
in quite nicely with its spectral appearance.
It might be navigating its way through a field
of other organisms, but it looks like it had
three minutes to prepare for a costume party
and decided to go with the classic “old
bedsheet with eyeholes” ghost costume.
And maybe comparing this flatworm (or even
worms in general) to a ghost is kind of apt.
Ghosts straddle two worlds, and so do worms,
though in their case, instead of bridging
the realm of the living and dead, worms manage
to stretch between the micro and the macro.
This creature you’re watching now would
probably be difficult to see without a microscope.
But on the other end, there are worms that
are meters too long to observe with a microscope.
And akin to ghosts, worms might seem like
a sort of reduced form of life.
After all, for a lot of us, worms are the
wiggly tubes that we dug up from playgrounds.
And of all of the worms, flatworms are perhaps
the most simple of all.
But even digging into what it means to be
the simplest worm makes the whole notion of
simplicity seem ludicrous.
So let’s start with the broader question:
what are worms, other than wiggly, self-mating tubes?
While we generally use the word “worm”
to describe many different, unrelated, invertebrate,
tubular animals that belong to a number of
different phyla, there are three main phyla
that people focus on.
The first are our flatworm buddies here, who
are known more formally as Platyhelminthes.
Then there is the phylum Nematoda, known less
formally as roundworms.
We’ve come across nematodes many times in
our journey through the microcosmos, which
makes sense given that they are one of the
most abundant animals on this planet.
And last are the Annelida, phylum of our playground
friend, the earthworm.
While earthworms are a bit beyond the scope
of the micro, if you will, we’ve also got
this little Stylaria lacustris.
At the tip of its head is the proboscis, an
antenna-like structure that the worm uses for feeding.
And as we scan past the head, you can see that the length of the Stylaria’s body is segmented.
Of the three phyla we’ve mentioned, annelids
are the most complex.
They have a closed circulatory system with
tubes that transport nutrients and oxygen
throughout their body, as well as a complete
digestive system that has both a mouth to
take in food and an anus to get rid of waste.
If we think of worms in general as a gut enclosed
within a body wall, then that gut is a tube
and the body is a tube, and you can imagine
that worms are a tube inside a tube.
Now what separates these different groups is the space that separates one of those tubes from the other.
Complex systems inside annelids are due to
what’s called a coelom, a tissue-lined cavity
that sits between the tube of the digestive
tract and the tube of the body wall.
Importantly, this cavity is filled with fluid,
which facilitates the development of organs
along with the transport of nutrients around
the body.
The development of the first coelom was a
very big deal because coeloms don’t just
allow annelids to have complex systems.
They connect the seemingly simple organisms we’re talking about here to more complex animals—like us!
Because annelids and humans are both what
is known as coelomates, or eucoelomates.
We are animals that have coeloms.
So, thank you to the ancestor that we share
with earthworms who developed the first coelom,
who allowed more complex organisms like you
to exist.
Nematodes, on the other hand, are what are
called pseudocoelomates.
They still have a coelom-like fluid-filled
cavity, but the cavity isn’t lined with
tissue like you find in true coeloms.
Other microscopic pseudocoelomates include
gastrotrichs and rotifers.
This pseudocoelom is a slight but significant
difference in nematodes when compared to annelids,
corresponding to a slightly less complex body plan, though nematodes
still do have a complete digestive system.
The flatworms are the simplest of all.
Starting with the coelom: flatworms don’t
actually have one.
They’re considered acoelomates.
That area between the gut and body wall where
annelids and nematodes have a cavity full
of fluid is instead full of tissue.
This has a few consequences for the flatworm,
but one of the biggest ones is that this area
can’t support the development of specialized
systems that you see in other animals.
The lack of coelom imposes limits on the flatworm’s
body and lifestyle, reducing both its complexity
and size.
But that does not mean the flatworm lives
a simple life.
Of the three worm groups, flatworms are the
most like a tube within another tube, except
that their outer tube is much less cylindrical.
The “flat” in “flatworm” is actually
an adaptation: without a circulatory system
or respiratory system, the worm relies on
diffusion across its outer membrane to supply
cells with oxygen.
Being flatter gets the cells closer to the
outside and better positioned for diffusion.
And without the ability to build a complete
digestive system like those found in nematodes
and annelids, flatworms have to adjust to
life without that most under-appreciated body
part of all: the anus.
They take in food through one opening, digest
it in their gut, and then spew the waste back
out from that same opening.
So unlike other organisms who have separate
entrances and exits for their food, the flatworm
must wait to finish digesting before it can
eat again.
But this is not the only way flatworms can
get rid of waste.
Their body is lined with a special type of
cell called a flame cell that also gets waste
out of the worm.
While it may not have the elegance of an interconnected
set of organs, this system is its own form
of complexity.
Basically, every flame cell is one single-celled kidney, allowing the worm to just...ooze waste from its skin.
And this is just scratching the surface of
the biological intricacy flatworms are capable of.
Like many of their more involved worm counterparts,
flatworms can reproduce both asexually and sexually.
And when reproducing sexually, they can mate
with another flatworm, or even with themselves--both
making and fertilizing their own eggs.
There’s also those flatworm species that
can regenerate, a trick that our more developed
bodies are, alas, not capable of.
Even the many weird ways they move make the
word “wiggle” feel reductive.
Our perception of simplicity across nature
is built on comparisons.
Compared to us, an earthworm may seem simple.
Put that earthworm next to a flatworm, and
suddenly the earthworm represents a gigantic
biological advancement.
But then put that flatworm next to a bacteria,
and suddenly it contains multitudes, it is a universe.
That flatworm is a marvel, an almost unbelievable
testament to the power of evolution.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Like a lot of people, you might be working
from home right now, and there can be a lot
of unique struggles that come along that.
Thanks to Skillshare classes like “Work
from Home as a Creative” you can learn new
strategies to make your work from home days
even more efficient!
Host Amarilys Henderson is a commercial illustrator who will teach you some creative strategies
for staying on top of your task and overall
just
being the most productive at-home creator you can be.
And Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
With so much to explore, real projects to
create, and the support of fellow-creatives,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth.
And it makes it easy with short classes that'll
fit into your daily routine.
A Premium Membership will give you unlimited
access, so you can join the classes and communities
that are right for you.
And an annual subscription to Skillshare is
less than $10 a month, and if you’re one
of the first 1,000 people to click the link
in the description, you can get a 2 month
free trial of Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
And thank you of course to all of the people
whose names are on the screen right now.
These are the people who make this channel
possible.
So, if you like it, you have them to thank.
Thank you so much to all our patrons.
If you are interested in becoming one of them,
you can go check it out at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.